giant locusts lifeless CGI a poorly made
Exorcist rip-off bad movies get released
all the time and we suffered through
them so you don't have to here are the
worst films of 2022 the sixth movie in
the Jurassic Park series in the third
entry in the reboot Trilogy launched in
2015 Jurassic world's Dominion Fields
designed to gobble up money the way its
unhinged dinosaurs gobble up prey but it
would seem that filmmakers have returned
to the formula one too many times to
make a decent movie even one that
features hyper realistic dinos set four
years after the events of Jurassic world
Fallen Kingdom dinosaurs now roam the
world terrorizing and hunting humans and
other creatures shooting themselves to
the top of the food chain so it's too
bad the movie decides to spend a good
chunk of its run time focused on an
outbreak of giant locusts
foreign
of course that's not the only problem
with this sequel according to Rotten
Tomatoes Dominion is by far the most
critically Savaged trip to the Jurassic
lands yet amassing a willful 30 rating
critic Tim Brayton of alternate ending
wrote of the movie The Last Time
dinosaurs were subjected to a disaster
this bad there was an asteroid involved
after some promising short films Anna
gutto made her feature screenwriting and
directorial debut with Paradise Highway
One couldn't ask for a better cast for
their first big movie as it stars
likable action Mainstay Frank Grillo and
two Academy Award winners in the
legendary Morgan Freeman and Juliet
binoche the problem is this Talent is
woefully miscast in order to save her
brother from Peril Southern trucker
Sally is forced to transport illegal
cargo which turns out to be a little kid
kid had been in this cage
Grillo isn't in the movie much existing
primarily as a disembodied voice on one
end of a phone line but Nosh just isn't
believable as a tough foul-mouthed woman
of the road Freeman despite being well
over 80 years old plays a heart as Nails
FBI agent Paradise Highway also suffers
from a lurid plot it's CD salacious for
the sake of being salacious and even
exploitative the story should allow for
intensity but it never comes to pass the
New York Times dinged the movie for a
lack of interesting tension most other
critics concurred as Paradise Highway
earned a truly dismal Rotten Tomato
score big gold brick tells the story of
young writer Samuel Liston as he
attempts to write the biography of Floyd
Devereux a middle-aged father the film
takes great pains to let the viewers
know is Corky nearly every event in big
old brick is a smug contrivance the tire
simile pretentious Samuel and the
obnoxiously weird Floyd meet when the
latter hits the former with his car
Samuel is then the audience surrogate
into the world of Floyd's family which
big gold brick relentlessly insists as
whack key and interesting but are really
just a third rate bunch of Royal
tenenbaum's Kooks critics hated big gold
brick giving it a lowly 20 rating on
Rotten Tomatoes Disney's live-action
remakes of its classic animated features
have had far from a Flawless critical
track record but even the subpar quality
of previous outings couldn't have
prepared people for the Studio's
underwhelming new take on Pinocchio
helmed by Robert zemeckis this 2022
update on Pinocchio didn't offer
anything to improve on the film it was
remaking instead replacing the
complicated tone of the original feature
with lifeless CGI and dumb bits of
modern comedy the idea to render this
iteration of the little wooden boy as
such a passive figure was just one of
many baffling Concepts in this remake
which also suffered from an
overabundance of CGI and a terrible
reimagining of Jiminy Cricket worst of
all this project roped in and wasted the
valuable time of Tom Hanks who was
conscripted to play Geppetto his
presence doesn't enliven the film so
much as it reminds audiences how every
artist assembled here could have spent
their time far more wisely
jumping Jeepers he's alive if there's
any major upside to this new version of
Pinocchio it's that it made the
stop-motion animated Guillermo del Toro
take on this same fairy tale all the
easier to appreciate when it dropped a
few months later until the end of time
people will be trying to recapture the
lightning in a bottle success of The
Exorcist
the power of Christ compels you
the power of Christ Belgium
that horror movie made exorcisms a go-to
practice to hinge new films around
though despite the ubiquity of such
titles few have managed to even come
close to the quality of The Exorcist
even many of the sequels to that William
friedkin horror film have been
disappointingly shallow rather than
frightening unfortunately for moviegoers
looking for solid horror Cinema pray for
the Devil is yet another forgettable dud
in the expansive Canon of Exorcist
knockoffs it's no surprise that critics
have been heavily disappointed with the
meager scares prey for the devil offers
up with specific criticism being lobbed
at how derivative its atmosphere is of
other exorcism movies as well as a
disjointed narrative that's more
distracting than Eerie worst of all are
the repeated criticisms that pray for
the Devil is above all else monotonous
rather than memorably bad the movie's
mechanical approach to becoming The
Exorcist of 2022 means that it's simply
tedious a lifeless rehash of the past
two lacking in a pulse to deliver
idiosyncratic shortcomings you got my
invitation
writer and director David O Russell shot
for the moon with Amsterdam which
brought together a staggering Ensemble
of talent to portray the various players
in a dark comedy set in the early
Decades of the 20th century the whole
Enterprise is plagued by among other
shortcomings an inescapable sense of
lifelessness particularly in the
cinematography and half-hearted
deliveries of seemingly big jokes it
also turns out that bringing together so
many famous actors isn't all that
compelling if you don't give them
something interesting to do the flaws in
Amsterdam are endless right down to
Christian Bale's performance which pulls
off the hat-trick of being both too
hammy and severely lacking in a
discernible personality that's what
we've become
moment of weakness worst of all though
is its run time which stretches out the
movie's thin plot for roughly 135
minutes there really is no advantage to
such a prolonged length Beyond making
one even more conscious of this
feature's various flaws all of the big
names Russell secured for Amsterdam's
cast may have looked snazzy on a poster
but none of them were able to salvage
this empty disaster
Lamborghini The Man Behind The Legend
offers up its take on the life of
ferruccio Lamborghini and specifically
his drive to defeat rival Enzo Ferrari
during the Geneva Grand Prix Ford vs
Ferrari demonstrated in 2019 that dudes
engaging in automobile focused rivalries
can be quite exciting and compelling but
Lamborghini offered the disastrous flip
side to that feature what's it take I'll
take something money came by when you
can buy speed wasn't about speed this
title written and directed by Bobby
maresco was critically Savaged upon its
release and largely dismissed as a
disposable tedious Motion Picture top of
the list of recurring critiques about
the movie is how Lamborghini doesn't
offer much Insight or unique
perspectives on its Central subject
there's nothing in here either
narratively or visually to make
Lamborghini stand out from countless
other similar biopics the performances
from actors like Frank Grillo get
slightly better marks than other aspects
of the production but even these
performers can't keep a film this dismal
afloat whether you're looking for a
movie that offers something new to say
about the life of ferruccio Lamborghini
or just an exciting movie about cars
Lamborghini is bound to leave you
disappointed in his time as an actor
Russell Crowe has headlined several
acclaimed films unfortunately his second
feature-length directorial effort Poker
Face wasn't greeted with the same level
of a claim on the contrary this suspense
thriller was met with disdain from
critics who largely found this title to
be an utterly forgettable outing Crow
has often made incredibly bold choices
as a performer that love them or hate
them do ensure his work as an actor
sticks around in your mind by contrast
poker face has been largely criticized
for being so generic the most critical
flaw highlighted time and time again in
the reviews for poker face is that it's
designed to be a movie that keeps you on
the edge of your seat yet its storyline
and characters are incredibly
predictable nothing in here is all that
Innovative nor effective at Conjuring up
suspense the mostly listless
performances from The Supporting Cast
which includes Liam Hemsworth also
garnered negative marks as an actor
Crow's reputation is largely
unimpeachable his skills in that area
though are sorely missing when it came
to his filmmaking shops on Poker Face
a historical fantasy that spent years in
production hell the King's Daughter
Stars Pierce Brosnan as king Louis XIV
of France who sends his men to search
for a mythical mermaid Louis wants to
live forever and he believes the magical
properties of the mermaid will make that
happen his plan gets derailed when his
illegitimate daughter learns of the
mermaid's existence this place is so
beautiful
this isn't one of those films that's so
bad it's good it's just straight up bad
and we mean bad January has long been a
Dumping Ground for unwatchable movies
but the King's Daughter was just too
terrible to fly under the radar despite
being based on a prize-winning novel The
King's Daughter is an adaptation of the
book the moon and the sun which won the
nebula award in 1997. it's a fantastic
read but the movie does the book a huge
disservice Paramount removed the film
from its release schedule just weeks
before it was due to hit Cinemas in 2015
with no explanation a source close to
the production told The Hollywood
Reporter that the delay was due to the
visual effects being incomplete and that
the movie would drop in a few mums
however years would pass before it saw
the light of day and when that
eventually happened it was easy to see
why it was hidden away for so long the
big stars chew the scenery as the film
meanders to an unsatisfying finish
Sony's Spider-Man universe has included
the financially successful and
critically moderately received Venom and
Venom Let There Be Carnage and in 2022
the latest entry morbius hit theaters
earning some of the worst reviews for
film based on a Comics property in more
than a decade An Origin story of the
titular living vampire morbius Stars
Jared Leto as Michael morbius a
scientist who cures himself of a blood
disorder with an experimental treatment
of his own design of course he also
accidentally makes himself a special
kind of vampire one who feasts on the
blood of humans but who also has
superpowers these Powers fuel his epic
battle for the ages against Milo morbius
his surrogate brother who has the same
blood disease contracts the same Powers
but becomes the Monstrous vampire
counterpart to Michael Stark heroism
let's have some fun
according to professional film critics
morbius is the worst film yet in Sony's
Spider-Man adjacent Cinematic Universe
scoring a lowly 16 on Rotten Tomatoes
[Music]